Nikhil: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Cadbury chocolates
in the UK and in India.
This is "Food Wars."
Cadbury Dairy Milk in India
comes in ranges of four sizes.
No. 1 is Cadbury Dairy Milk minis.
It comes in this large packet
with 18 smaller pieces of 7 grams each.
Our smallest are these
bite-size 11-gram bars.
Then we have these 18-gram little bars.
A simple 24-grams tiny one.
Next up we have our multipack bars,
which weigh 33.5 grams.
The standard individual Dairy
Milk bar weighs 45 grams.
The duo bar, which comes in two halves
and weighs 54.4 grams.
Then a 55-grams maha pack.
Next up we have this 110-gram bar.
Family pack, 126 grams.
Then we move to a 180-gram bar.
We have this 360-gram bar.
The biggest size you'll find in the UK
is an 850-gram giant bar.
So, in India, Cadbury is really well known
for its gift boxes.
In fact, they've done so much
marketing over so many years
that it's become synonymous
with festivals like Diwali,
Dussehra, and even
Christmas and New Year's.
On their website right
now, you can get anything
from an anniversary tin
box to a Ramadan tin box.
And they come in several different sizes.
For starters, there's a
standard personalized gift box,
which contains six
Cadbury Dairy Milk bars,
three of which are Silk and
three of which are standard.
And that's the one we have right here.
In fact, they've put my face on it!
I mean, that's a whole lot of packaging
for normal bars of chocolate
you can just buy, I guess.
It even says "Food Wars"!
Oh, it says US versus India. Sorry, Harry.
Apart from this, you can also get
a larger personalized birthday gift box,
which will contain 450 grams of Silk bars,
three birthday whistles, a
large banner, a birthday hat.
So the next time you don't know what to do
for your birthday, just
order this to your house,
and you can have a party by yourself.
Now, we have some
gift-box items of our own,
but they usually come more in
the form of selection boxes.
These are most commonly
seen around Christmastime,
at which point Cadbury's will
release Heroes and Roses,
which are selection boxes
containing 600 grams
of individually wrapped chocolates.
It's a real tradition
in British households
to have a few of these lying around.
The other options include
Quality Street and Celebrations.
People tend to have their own favorites
when it comes to the selection boxes
and also the chocolates inside them.
I think generally Heroes would be
my preferred option over Roses.
I prefer the kind of more
mainstream chocolate bars
that you'll find, including
little Wispa bites,
which I think might be my favorites.
If you want a gift option
for all year round,
opt for a Milk Tray. These
have been around for decades.
I think my mum used to
be giving these to people
when she was growing up.
And for the run-up to Christmas,
you gotta get yourself an Advent calendar.
I don't think I'd normally
go for one of these.
These are a little bit
flimsy, quite narrow.
But still, you get a lot of joy
from opening a tiny bite
of chocolate every morning
in the run-up to Christmas.
Here are all the Cadbury products
that you'll find in India that
you will not find in the UK.
Here are all the Cadbury
products from the UK
that you won't find in India.
This is so much chocolate.
In terms of our classic
Dairy Milk flavors,
we have two exclusives.
No. 1, roast almond, and No. 2, crackle.
This used to be my favorite as a child,
but right now I really like this.
Delicious chunks of roast almond.
We have some exclusive Dairy
Milk flavors of our own.
Firstly, for the
health-conscious among us,
we have this 30% less sugar Dairy Milk.
I guess this could be helpful as well
if you find regular milk
chocolate too sweet,
which some people do,
but then I guess just opt for
some dark chocolate instead.
Next up we have Cadbury caramel.
It's a bar of Dairy Milk,
but inside each square there's
a little bit of caramel.
This is one of my favorite ones.
It does get a little bit sickly
if you eat too much of it
because of the amount of
sugar, but very tasty.
We have some Big Taste bars,
which are chunky versions of Dairy Milk,
starting with peanut caramel crisp.
And we also have a triple
choc sensation Big Taste bar,
which combines dark,
milk, and white chocolate
in one delicious bar.
These ones look really cool.
They've definitely put a bit more thought
into the design of the bars.
Tastes really good as well.
Next up, we've got Dairy
Milk with Crunchie bits.
Now, this is Crunchie with an
-ie, not crunchy with a -y.
Crunchie with an -ie is
actually a bar of chocolate
you can get here in the UK.
It's milk chocolate
with a honeycomb center.
Then we have a Dairy Milk Daim bar.
Daim is another chocolate bar
which Dairy Milk has
kind of collabed with.
I think it's a very thin,
brittle almond-caramel bar
with a little bit of
chocolate on the outside.
My granddad really used to like Daim.
Then we have this Marvellous Creations
jelly popping candy bar.
As the name suggests,
it's a bar of chocolate
which contains some popping candy
as well as I think jelly beans.
I've not tried this in a long time.
I want to see what the ratios are like
and also if I can really
feel the popping candy.
You can see a couple of bits of,
I assume, jelly beans
peeking out of the top.
The pattern is kind of odd.
Usually obviously you have squares.
Makes it nice and easy
to break apart and share.
I'm just gonna bite into it like a madman.
You really do get the popping
candy. My mouth is popping.
[popping]
It's actually not too bad.
You get little chewy sweet
bits in with your chocolate.
There's a lot going on,
but I don't hate it.
For vegans in the UK, Cadbury's
also has a plant-based bar.
I've never tried this, so I want to see
if I can taste the difference
between this and Dairy Milk.
I mean, it looks like chocolate.
Definitely does taste
of almond, which is OK,
'cause I quite like kind
of nut and chocolate
as a combination. If I went vegan,
I don't know if I'd be rushing
to the store to buy this.
It's OK. The texture's pretty good,
but the flavor just really isn't there.
Our last two exclusive Dairy Milk bars
are actually a mystery.
Two bars which contain
fillings of a mystery flavor.
You try and guess what the flavor is,
and then you can submit
your answer online.
Myself and the rest of the
crew have now got to try these
and give our best
guesses. Mystery bar one.
Oh, God. The last time
I threw stuff at you
it didn't go very well.
Leon: I've got it.
Harry: Ooh.
OK, it's fruity. Currently
we're thinking maybe rose.
I'm personally thinking apricot.
Struggling to agree here.
We can taste more. Swear I get fruit.
While we figure that one out,
we'll try mystery bar No. 2.
Now, this one smells aggressively fruity.
Catch, Leon.
I'm getting quite a lot of, like,
very artificial raspberry flavor.
I'd be fairly confident in
asserting that as raspberry.
It might be blueberry.
Plot twist, they've already
revealed the flavors.
We didn't know.
First one was rhubarb and
custard. Classic British dessert.
Didn't really get very close to that one.
Second was blue raspberry,
which we actually did kind of get.
I personally don't think I would buy
either of those again, though.
Charlie: Maybe the first one.
Harry: You don't mind it?
And now for our Silk range,
or, as Cadbury is trying
to rebrand it, the S range.
What is this? Some sort of new iPhone?
But whether you call it Silk
or S, I love these chocolates.
First off, we have the typical Silk.
Basically it's just Dairy
Milk but a lot silkier.
Then we have Dairy Milk Silk bubbly.
It's Dairy Milk Silk, but bubbly.
That's nice, light, airy.
Next, you have a Dairy
Milk Silk fruit and nut.
Then we have Dairy Milk Silk hazelnut.
Wow, there are some proper
large chunks of hazelnut.
The hazelnut itself,
the flavor of it really
lends to the chocolate,
and it doesn't taste as sweet.
Next up we have Dairy
Milk Silk roast almond.
We have Dairy Milk Silk mousse.
They've tried to recreate
the flavor of mousse,
and you can see that
it's a lot more fudgy,
the chocolate inside.
It's all right.
Oh, man, there's one
that I'm scared to try.
Dairy Milk Silk bubbly bubble gum.
Oh, no, I saw the color of it.
Oh, my God, why have they done this?
Growing up, we had a
bubble gum called Boomer,
which is now what we have all become.
That one bite was really not that bad.
It definitely tastes like bubble gum
and gave me that Boomer vibe.
That's as much as I can have of that.
Now, to cleanse the palate, Silk Oreo.
Mm!
That has a nice flavor to it.
I think this is my
favorite out of the lot.
We also have another variation of Oreo.
It's red velvet Oreo.
If you've watched previous
episodes of "Food Wars,"
you'll remember that
one of the ingredients
that has taken India by
storm in the past few decades
is red velvet.
And I have tasted this before,
and I actually think it's really good.
But it is overkill.
It's literally Dairy Milk
Silk, the Oreo white cream,
and chunks of Oreo that have
been turned into red velvet.
Do you have a treadmill?
Finally, we have Dairy
Milk Silk heart blush.
I imagine you give this to your loved one.
It says "pull" over here,
and I'm pretty excited to pull this.
"Never gonna give you up.
Never gonna let you down."
I can't believe I've been
Rickrolled in my own video!
At the back, there is a very
elaborate-looking tear tab,
so I'm just gonna ... ah!
Not very easy to -- wait, what?
I'd probably break up
with whoever gave me this
at this point. This is frustrating.
It's more packaging.
All right.
More packaging.
This is honestly a very wasteful way
to tell somebody you like them.
There you go. It's some pink chocolate.
Oh, my God, I swear to God,
if it's the same as the
bubble gum, I'm gonna cry.
It's not bubble gum, so.
This is actually quite a fun
experience, I'm not gonna lie.
Now, we don't have Silk bars,
but we do have something called Darkmilk.
Cadbury's has kind of invented this hybrid
milk and dark chocolate
for someone whose tastes
lie somewhere between those two.
Here is the Darkmilk.
Darkmilk also comes in variations
including a salted-caramel
flavor and a hazelnut flavor.
I feel like they've tried to
market these a little bit more
at adults, maybe, as opposed to kids.
The packaging kind of gives
a slightly more sophisticated
vibe. Sexy, if you will.
At the other end of
the scale, we have some
even sweeter options than
classic milk chocolate.
Firstly, we have Caramilk,
which is golden caramel chocolate.
This one I have not tried.
I'm kind of intrigued.
I'm going to have a bite.
I worry it's going to be far too sweet.
Wow, that's very sweet.
You do get notes of caramel,
but I really don't think I could eat
more than a couple of bites of that.
And, of course, we also
just have white chocolate.
As I've said, I'm not really
a big fan of white chocolate,
and I don't think I'm alone in that,
because this basically wasn't available
in any of the big
supermarkets that I looked in.
The shop we were able to track
it down in was Poundland,
which is a shop in the UK
where everything costs a pound.
I know it sounds ridiculous
to an American audience,
but that is what it's called.
So, you can find Cadbury
Bournville dark chocolate
in both the UK and in India,
but there's a slight difference.
In the UK, the packaging
is bright red, ew,
and over here we have different flavors,
50% dark chocolate and 70% dark chocolate.
I have over the years grown
to like dark chocolate.
I was never a fan of it growing up.
But 70% dark chocolate? I don't know.
Oh!
You know, it's not as bitter
as I expected. Very creamy.
Also, the cocoa is 100%
sustainably sourced.
Next up, we have a fruit and nut.
It's got a peanut in there.
It doesn't taste as heavy
as the other chocolates
I've had so far, and I
really appreciate this.
Am I growing old? Is
that what's happening?
And the final flavor is cranberry,
which I've been the most excited about.
I don't think I've had any chocolate bars
that have had cranberry in them,
but obviously cranberry and dark chocolate
sounds like an amazing combination.
That is so good! The
tartness of the cranberry
and, like, the slight sugariness
really complements the dark chocolate.
There's the crunch of roasted
almond. This is a winner.
Real nice. I like this
range of Bournvilles.
Feels like a healthier guilty pleasure.
We also have some Bournville products
you'll find in the UK that
you won't find in India.
Firstly, we have Bournville old Jamaica.
The "old Jamaica" refers
to rum and raisin flavors
added to the dark chocolate.
And we also have an orange Bournville.
I personally don't love dark chocolate,
and I especially do
not love dark chocolate
combined with fruit,
so I'm respectfully not
going to try any of these.
If you're wondering where the
name Bournville comes from,
it's actually a village that was created
by the Cadbury family for workers
who worked in their
factory near Birmingham.
Bournville still exists today,
so you can go and visit it.
It's home to Cadbury
World, which is a kind of
Cadbury museum
interactive-experience thing,
and apparently it's a
really nice place to live.
And now it's time for all of the remaining
Indian Cadbury products,
starting with Cadbury Fuse.
Their tagline for this is, "A
delicious chocolaty feast."
Like, some sort of chocolaty
mousse in the middle
surrounded by caramel,
and then the outer layer of
chocolate has peanuts in it.
So I can imagine this
being a proper feast.
Kind of nice.
I think I could eat this
much of one chocolate,
but the fact that I'm eating
so many varieties of chocolate
one after the other is really
doing something to my brain!
Like, why are we doing this?
No, like, what is this? Why
are we tasting all of this?
What is the point of this show?
Next in line, we have
the Cadbury Crispello.
I want to be on the team that gets to name
all of these chocolates.
Seems like you can just
get away with anything.
It's clearly filled
with some rice crispies
and things that are crispies.
Hey, this one is actually really yum.
Next up,
Cadbury 5 Star 3D.
If you don't know what 5
Star is, it's basically
the chocolate that made
caramel cool in India.
It's been around for decades,
and actually, fun fact,
it's my mom's favorite chocolate.
Now they've upgraded to 5 Star 3D.
What's the difference between
this and any other 5 Star?
It has nuts.
I will say, having eaten the
past three chocolates in a row,
I'm starting to realize
they're kind of the same thing.
It's decent. I prefer the original 5 Star.
That one sparks nostalgia.
This one just feels too modern.
Next up, we have a Perk.
So, Perk is another chocolate
that's been around in India
for ages now, and it's gone
through a lot of evolutions,
like every other chocolate has.
Now they sell Perk in a double pack.
It says you can "rip it, share it."
Oh!
Next up, some gemstones.
That's right, the UK didn't
give us our gemstones back,
but they definitely gave us Gems.
Yeah, I mean, fair enough. Sorry, guys.
So, they're M&M's without
the M&M branding on top.
What I used to do as a kid,
you would get a small packet of Gems,
and I would suck on each gem
until the color would come off
and it would be a white gem.
And then I'd put all the
white ones in my mouth
and bite them like one big chocolate.
I was weird, and I had no friends.
Cadbury Temptations rum and raisin. Rum?
And, uh, Cad, Cadbury, Cadbrury -- whoo!
Cadbury Temptations almond treat.
It smells like rum.
Whoa, I did not expect that
flavor to be so strong.
Can they sell this to children?
It kind of tastes like
a Christmas rum cake.
Yeah, I don't mind it. I
think this could be a great
Christmas sort of
chocolate to have around.
Next up is my favorite
childhood chocolate, Nutties.
I freaking love Nutties,
and my favorite part about Nutties
is that the branding
has not really changed
for, like, decades now.
What this chocolate is, is
basically Cadbury chocolate
coated over a cashew nut
that's covered in nougat.
Oh, my God, that is so good.
Then we have a load more
Cadbury exclusives in the UK,
and we'll start with the bars.
We'll start with what is
technically a Cadbury product
but initially was not.
This is the Fry's chocolate cream bar.
It's a dark-chocolate bar
with a creamy, smooth fondant center.
A fun factor is that the
Frys were a Quaker family
who were the first ones to
actually commercially produce
chocolate bars in the UK.
Before the Frys came along,
drinking chocolate was kind
of the only way to consume it.
Fry's also makes a peppermint cream bar
as well as Turkish delight.
I will say, this is not the
best Turkish delight out there.
If you want Turkish delight,
go to a grocery store
that sells Turkish food,
get some classic stuff,
whereas this is a kind of
slightly cheapy Turkish delight
encased in chocolate.
Next up, we have Boost bars.
These are chocolate bars
filled with caramel and biscuit pieces.
When Boost was first launched,
I think they were kind of
marketed as almost an energy bar.
They had loads of sugar
and glucose in them,
although I think they have now
recently dropped that down,
and it's just in line more
with a standard chocolate bar.
Then we're on to Chomps.
I personally love a Chomp.
These were also a little bit hard to find.
I think we had to go to
Poundland for these ones as well,
but they used to cost, like, 10p
from your local news agents.
It's just a chocolate bar
with toffee/caramel inside.
Simple but effective.
Then we have Crunchie bars,
which are chocolate bars
with a large honeycomb center.
Personally, don't love Crunchie bars.
I don't love the texture of the honeycomb,
and they're very, very sweet.
What I do love, however, is a Curly Wurly.
These are brilliantly named.
They come in these little
individual bars, like this.
They look a bit weird.
It's kind of a web of
chocolate and caramel.
I used to have braces as a kid,
and I really missed toffee and
caramel while I had them on.
Moving on, we have a Double Decker bar.
A nod to the British double-decker buses,
this is a two-layered chocolate
bar with a nougat layer
as well as a kind of
crunchy-pieces-in-caramel layer.
I like these.
Next up, we have Fudge bars.
Got these little bite-sized
ones today. I like these.
The guys seem to disagree with me,
but I think these are good.
I will opt for these in a Heroes box.
It's just a bar of fudge
covered with chocolate.
Then we move on to the Picnic bar.
It's a chocolate bar that
contains, I think, caramel,
some rice-crispy kind of pieces,
as well as some raisins and peanuts.
Now, while India has a 5 Star bar,
in the UK, we just have a Starbar.
I don't think I've ever
had one of these before.
Apparently it's milk chocolate
with caramel and peanut.
Let's give it a try.
That might get added to
my rotation, you know?
That's pretty good.
Next up, we have the Twirl.
These are, like, ribboned chocolate bars
which are then kind of
cased within more chocolate.
It leads to quite an interesting texture
and quite a nice taste.
The only issue with Twirls
is that they do crumble
and kind of go everywhere.
You can also get Twirls
in an orange flavor.
Then we're on to Wispa bars. Shh.
I don't really know how they make these,
because it's milk chocolate,
but it's, like, aerated.
There's kind of little holes
all the way through it.
We put a man on the moon, and
we aerated a chocolate bar.
The result is a really
nice texture, actually.
It sort of melts in your
mouth when you eat it.
I've some American colleagues in the US.
Last time I visited,
this was the one thing they
asked me to bring over.
You can also get Wispa gold bars.
These are the same as regular Wispas,
but they have a layer of
caramel running along the top.
And the last-but-by-no-means-least
bar is the Freddo.
It's basically just a tiny
piece of solid milk chocolate
in the shape of Freddo the frog.
But for people of a certain
generation, namely mine,
they're also a surprising representation
of economic inflation.
To put on my angry-old-man
hat for a second,
when I was a youngin', these were 10p,
and then around 2005, prices
started to gradually creep up.
Before we knew it, prices were as high
as 30p for a Freddo.
These outrageous prices
actually led to public outcry,
so much so that they backed down,
and I think nowadays they're around 25p.
The Bank of England says
that it should have been
around 17 or 18p by now,
whereas we are getting charged 25,
so Cadbury's, give us
some cheap Freddos again.
Economic rant is now over.
You can also get Freddos
in a caramel flavor.
The last thing to add
to the chocolate bars
is that you can get
pretty much all of them
in the form of these share bags.
They basically just condense
them into bite-size pieces
and put them in a bag that
you can open and reseal.
Next up, we have Dairy Milk Bites.
There are two flavors
that we have right now,
hazelnut and almond.
They look pretty similar to
the Silk of these flavors,
so I imagine these are just
smaller bite-sized versions.
Next up, Lickables.
Why have they done this?
Thoughts on this? This is
clearly for small children.
Somebody want to help me? I
have no idea how to open this.
This feels like one of those puzzles.
Oh!
[crew clapping]
The lower half of it was a chocolate,
and the rest of it had this toy.
Now to the chocolate.
There's a QR code, because
most children have phones
that they can scan this with.
Oh!
Looks like goopy Cadbury chocolate
with chunks of Oreo,
and you just gotta lick it.
This is just weird, Cadbury.
OK, next up we have Cadbury Chocobakes
choc-filled cookies.
In case you didn't think
this contained chocolate,
they reminded you eight
times in the branding.
The packaging and the design
feels a lot more premium.
I feel like there's good
value for money here,
because it was filled to the literal brim.
Now we're going to go to this side.
We have Oreo dipped in Cadbury, damn.
I'm really enjoying this whole
Oreo-Cadbury marriage over here.
Now we have an Oreo biscuit
coated in Cadbury chocolate.
The Oreo biscuits are
just kind of overpowering,
so it's all right.
Next up we have this tin
can of rich dry fruits.
Again, in the Cadbury Celebrations line.
In India, a common gifting culture
is to give a box of dry fruits and nuts,
and so Cadbury's adapting
really well to that.
All right, so the next thing
is something very different.
This is actually Bournvita,
or Cadbury Bournvita,
and this is a drinking chocolate.
We drink a lot of milk here in India,
and as kids, everybody was addicted
to one of many different
drinking chocolates.
Horlicks, Complan, I'm a Milo guy myself.
There was Boost, and
then obviously Bournvita.
I think most people were
not Bournvita people.
This is Cadbury's range of choco melts,
and it's a small disk of
chocolate that's used for baking.
And finally, the last
three packets are toffees
that Cadbury sells in bulk.
This one is 5 Star bites.
It's similar to the Dairy Milk minis.
For all my Indian fans
of 5 Star out there,
comment and let me know whether you're
more of a Ramesh guy or Suresh guy.
These are packs of toffees.
Eclairs, to be specific.
This one is chocolate-flavored,
and this one is coffee-flavored.
Another quirky thing about India
is sometimes when you
go to the local stores
and you pay in cash and
they have to give you change
but they don't have any,
they'll just give you
one of these chocolates.
And you can't really argue
it, you just grab it and go.
I think it's very cute, actually.
It's a very endearing thing about India.
But remember, if you're gonna
take a chocolate from a store,
screw all this. Take Melody.
Melody is the best chocolate, all right?
In the UK, Cadbury's offers
a lot of seasonal products.
Now, we're recording this
episode in late October,
so unfortunately we can't get
some of the most famous ones.
What I'm of course referring to here
are Cadbury Creme Eggs
and Cadbury Mini Eggs.
In the UK, these are only available
in the run-up to the Easter holidays,
but while they are available,
they're wildly popular.
Well, I will say, I don't like Creme Eggs.
I take stick for this.
I think they're gross.
The fondant in the middle is grim.
You have to kind of, like, tongue it out.
It's just really bizarre.
Mini Eggs, however, are delicious.
I don't know what they're
putting in the shells
of those things, but,
God, they're amazing.
While we can't get the
Easter exclusives right now,
what we do have are Halloween
and Christmas options.
For Halloween, I was able
to find these Goo Heads.
I think these are kind
of the Halloween version
of Creme Eggs, so I'm going
to crack one open and see.
That does look exactly
the same as a Creme Egg,
even down to the patterning
that's printed on the egg.
I mean, yeah, that's pretty
much just a Creme Egg.
I just don't like them.
Now, for Christmas exclusives,
I found these Cadbury Puds.
These are Dairy Milk chocolate
balls with a truffle center,
hazelnut pieces, and rice crisps.
They sound pretty good.
We also found Cadbury Mini Snow Balls,
which are milk chocolate
in a crisp sugar shell.
They might hurt a little bit more
than a normal snowball fight
if you have one of these
thrown at your head.
And, of course, you can get a Dairy Milk
Advent calendar for Christmas.
It looks like some kind of mud monster.
Moving away from seasonal
items, we have Cadbury Eclairs.
Cadbury Eclairs are quite
tough pieces of toffee
with some chocolate in the center.
They're a pretty good jaw workout,
but I do quite like these.
And another iconic
Cadbury item is Buttons.
These are bags of disks
of Dairy Milk chocolate.
Real classic. These have
been around for years.
From there, we're moving on
to Cadbury's biscuit options,
possibly the most iconic
of which are Fingers.
These are thin sticks of sweet biscuit
covered in Dairy Milk chocolate.
They're very tasty,
they're pretty moreish,
and they come in these kind
of iconic sleeve-tray things.
I know with Joe we have a caffeine meter,
but if I had a sugar meter, pew!
We are blasting off right now. Whoo!
We also have some other flavor
options, including mint,
orange, Bournville dark,
and, finally, white.
Roundies are circular
layered wafer biscuits
covered in Dairy Milk chocolate.
If you're a fan of wafers,
you can also get Timeout Wafer bars.
Again, it's chocolate wafers
layered and surrounded by chocolate,
but this time in more of a bar
form than a circular biscuit.
The next Cadbury biscuits
option is Animals.
"Freddo has hopped into the
jungle to join his friends."
These are little animal-shaped biscuits
which on one side are
covered with chocolate.
I don't think I've eaten
one of these as an adult,
but they were an excellent
lunch-box addition
when I was a little kid.
I'd also be remiss not
to talk about Mini Rolls.
These are an iconic British snack.
What it is, is a chocolate sponge
with this kind of cream
swirl in the middle,
surrounded by milk chocolate.
I'm not sure why the Mini
Roll is currently saying,
"I'm rich and famous," but
good for the Mini Roll.
These are great.
Finally, Cadbury's offers
some baked options,
which you might find in the bakery section
of your local supermarket.
These can include things
like doughnuts and muffins,
but the ones I was able to
find today were flapjack bites.
In the UK, when we say flapjacks,
we don't mean pancakes,
which I think Americans can say sometimes.
Flapjacks over here are kind
of like oats held together
with honey, golden syrup,
and some other stuff.
And these mini cookies.
Here's everything in a bar
of Dairy Milk chocolate in the UK.
Here's everything you'll find in a bar
of Dairy Milk chocolate here in India.
So, the list of ingredients
is pretty much the same
in the UK and in India.
But the UK uses palm and shea fats,
which is not specifically
listed here in India.
India goes into a little bit
more detail on the flavorings
used in the chocolate,
listing natural vanillin
as well as artificial ethyl vanillin.
As the name suggests,
this is the main component
of vanilla-bean extract.
Some kind of vanillin is likely
present in the UK chocolate,
it's just contained within
the flavorings on the list.
But how much chocolate
are you actually getting
in your chocolate?
The Food Safety and
Standards Authority of India
has some minimum requirements
for what milk chocolate should contain.
The rules are 25% total fat, 2% milk fat,
2.5% cocoa solids, and 10.5% milk solids.
We have equivalent rules here in the UK.
The Cocoa and Chocolate
Products Regulations of 2003
set the minimums for milk
chocolate at 25% total fat,
5% milk fat, 20% dry cocoa solids,
2.5% dry nonfat cocoa solids,
and 20% dry milk solids.
Cadbury in the UK says
its chocolate contains
23% milk solids
and meets the EU minimum
of 20% for cocoa solids.
India's Cadbury packaging says it contains
over 22% milk solids.
So thank you, Cadbury,
for not being chindi.
It is interesting that Indian
rules do not have a minimum
for dry fat-free cocoa
solids in milk chocolate.
The dark chocolates, however,
have a minimum, and it's 14%.
"Dry cocoa solids" tends
to refer to cocoa powder,
which is one of the purest forms of cocoa.
Having more cocoa solids
therefore gives the end product
a stronger chocolate taste.
100 grams of Dairy Milk in
the UK contains the following.
100 grams of Dairy Milk in India contains:
The calories are actually identical.
The least-healthy bar in the UK
is the Big Taste toffee whole nut bar.
One of these contains 560
calories per 100 grams,
a slight increase on Dairy Milk.
But what is the least-healthy
chocolate bar here in India?
It's the Dairy Milk Silk hazelnut.
100 grams of this contains 571 calories,
which is more than any bar in the UK.
I guess it's a win? I'm
counting it as a win.
Anyways, I'm gonna go on a long run,
because I definitely have
diabetes at this point.
Thank you for watching.
Make sure to subscribe to the channel.
It pays for my hospital bills.